I think watching is going to be a very
critical technology for the future
development of the world it's not only
about the financial blockchain
technology is not about bitcoins Bitcoin
is just a small function of the
blockchain technology I'm a strong
believer of the blockchain technology
this is not about Bitcoin or digital
currencies or crypto assets it's the
underlying blockchain technology now
people can trust each other and they can
transact with anything for money - music
- votes - their identities peer-to-peer
the cleanest MySpace or Facebook I don't
know but watching is socially so at the
macro block scenes going over right like
watching is here to stay forever and
it's a very good
enter blockchain Satoshi Nakamoto 2008
anonymous person came up with this way
of people transacting doing business
with assets peer-to-peer and Trust is
not achieved by a middleman it's
achieved by cryptography by
collaboration and by some clever code
and what that means is that we now have
a native digital medium for value
effectively a software distributed
database that's managed independently
and that inerrant Li that inherent
combination makes it a utility it makes
it software effectively that has value
in the chip
[Music]
the business world of the future say ten
years from now it's gonna run on smart
contracts it's going to run on strong
encryption and on you know peer to peer
based consensus mechanisms so the core
technologies underlying blockchain are
going to pervade everything just like
the Internet has just like
object-oriented software has right now
so the choice when I talk to people is
what do you think will be here in 2040
approximate 22 years from now
well goal so be here well it's been here
since eternity well the dollar will the
dollar be here I don't think so
and I can be here I think so
we think a Bitcoin has a digital gold so
gold 2.0 but its money the first of the
money that was ever built purposely for
the internet so it's sort of like what
your email did to steal mail
cryptocurrency or Bitcoin does for money
well bitcoin is exciting because it
shows how cheap it can be Bitcoin is is
better than currency and that you don't
have to be physically in the same place
and of course the large transactions
currency can get pretty inconvenient the
customers we're talking about aren't
trying to be anonymous you know they're
willing to be known so McClane
technologies key and you could add to it
or you could build a similar technology
where there's enough attribution that
people feel comfortable this is nothing
to do with terrorism or any type of
money laundering
it's still very early institutions
everybody knows about it everyone's
heard about it and there's some very
sophisticated people in even these banks
who know about cryptocurrency but
they're still not really in the game yet
it's still very much a retail to the
market very much a lot of the actions
out in Asia so we we still think it's at
the bottom of the first inning it's if
you read this book you understand how we
got here
and how far it's come but it's also just
sort of the beginning in a lot of ways
well I think it is there will be other
currencies like it that may may be even
better but in the meantime there's a big
industry around Bitcoin and you know
people have made fortunes that Bitcoin
some people lost minute a Bitcoin it's
not it's volatile yeah but it is high
volatile but good you know when in
public say productivity people can make
money have deposits so we're a secret
respectively as a replacement for cash
but not as a replacement for as a
primary or not as I do not secretive
being the primary database
[Music]
I would say there is a lot of need for
developers even at the core protocol
layer and so things like improving
protocol scalability working on the
client of limitations implementations of
things like burgers sake leer tuna
systems to sixteen channels in plasma it
could probably use a lot more smart
people on the application stuff and I
guess you could always use more but
there's probably quite a lot more of
that already